how are you my god it's been so long no
last time we saw each other it was
Geneva
it was Geneva you were to wine bar and
there was a violin player in the corner
and we had a great yes yes yes okay so
maybe we didn't actually get weird in
Geneva but things definitely got a
little crazy at the Critics Choice
Awards and we talked about making out
with Christian Bale
tell me all about it I want to know I
want to dive into this Christian Bale is
a very passionate actor I'm a passionate
director we also you know like emotions
flow and when we won the Critics Choice
Award we both looked at each other and
we just said this is happening you
locked eyes and you knew and it didn't
stop in that moment it continued in a
cabana no it's the big short has been
the talk of this award season but we
also have our fingers crossed for
McKay's writing skills on the ant-man
sequel
well you're not writing a man in the box
right not quite yet I'm talking to
Peyton I'm talking to Rudd I have some
ideas we'll see what happens see what
happens but I'm always loyal to Marvel I
loved working with Kevin Feige and
they're amazing what they do